bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nos ce matin quel bilan vous faites
à l'issue de cette convention citoyenne
pour le climat alors cette convention
citoyenne globalement aller assez
décevante puisque on a là un band
l'impression d'un grand gaspillage 17
mois de travaux et au final le sentiment
que cet exercice de démocratie
participative
il laisse un peu ce sentiment d'inachevé
de frustration en cas les citoyens
par exemple un grand point de
questionnements des citoyens ça a aidé
la transposition de la reconnaissance du
crime descossy d'un droit français qui a
été notée à 2,7 pour 2.7 pardon sur 10
donc une très mauvaise note et ça
faisait partie évidemment des
revendications centrales de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat au
final vous avez réellement le sentiment
de ne pas avoir été compris votre avis
de citoyenne qui n'a pas été prises en
compte donc par ce gouvernement dans
dans sa globalité alors son âme et à des
ces questionnaires puisque à de
nombreuses reprises les citoyens et puis
mieux les organisations comme la nôtre
qui est soutenait ce mouvement ont été
reçus par les ministères mais entre
l'écoutent et un véritable échange
on peut dire qu'il ya une frontière qui
n'a pas réussi à être franchie puisque
nous n'avons pas eu de véritable
sentiment de d'aboutir dans nos
discussions qu'il n'y a pas eu forcément
de négociations mais qu'au contraire le
gouvernement a posé sur la table son
texte et qu'au final notre marge de
manoeuvre était inexistante c'est ça qui
a créé ce sentiment de frustration je
pense aussi auprès des citoyens
au total il ya eu je crois 150
propositions
qu'est ce qu'on retient finalement de de
cette convention citoyenne pour le
climat au niveau des propositions que
vous avez formulées alors nous allons
nous battre en fait continue à me battre
en fait pendant les débats
parlementaires puisque de l'avis des
institutions il faut encore en fait
réorienter la loi vert
en fait de meilleurs objectifs
c'est-à-dire pour les délais qui sont
trop long et bien les raccourcir pour
les mesures qui sont trop molle et ben
les renforcer pour pouvoir a minima
halte indre donc 40 - 40 % d'émissions
de gaz à effet de serre d'ici 2030
c'était l'objectif que le gouvernement
s'est lui même fixé donc il doit au
moins respecter cet engagement et ces
mesures là donc nous allons évidemment
continuer nous sommes en discussion en
fait avec les parlementaires qui
voudront bien j'espère déposer des
amendements sur le texte afin de
renforcer ses propositions pour les
échos citent par exemple soutenu par
l'association white lies gueule nous
allons demander évidemment la
modification du délit d' écocide qui est
un titre trompeur en fait associé à un
délit de pollution pour avoir une vraie
discussion sur le fond concernant la
reconnaissance d'un crime des costils et
donc pas d'un délit qu'ils soient
sanctionnés qui donc cuisse apporter une
vraie solution en matière d'atteinte
grave et tendue ou durable à
l'environnement
alors les citoyens qui étaient présents
lors de cette convention at river notre
note assez médiocre au gouvernement de 5
sur 10
comment vous l'expliquez et bien encore
une fois c'est que finalement le débat
aurait pu avoir lieu et loeb l'ambition
de cette convention citoyenne
au départ c'était tout de même de
répondre à sentiment de frustration qui
c'est qui avaient émergé durant la crise
des gilet jaune or on voit que
finalement le gouvernement reste dans sa
position c'est à dire en hauteur
finalement au lieu de discuter de
manière horizontale avec les citoyens et
donc forcément on a entretenu ce
sentiment de séparation entre l'état et
le peuple et ça crée évidemment ce
sentiment d'injustice de frustration ce
que je retiens c'est que ces 150
citoyens à aujourd'hui ce sont des
militants acharnés ce sont des
activistes du climat et donc ce sont les
gens qui aujourd'hui qu'on entend qu'on
entendra j'espère qu'on continuera d'en
temps nous par la suite qu'ils sont
monté contre emmanuel macron je ne sais
pas si pour lui c'était vraiment une
bonne idée de ne pas tenir compte des
engagements fin des propositions de la
convention citoyens pour les mains car
il va avoir finalement beaucoup de mal à
convaincre qu'il a réussi à tenir ses
engagements climatiques et en matière de
protection de l'environnement tout cas
quand on vous entend on a le sentiment
que finalement cette convention
citoyenne pour le climat c'est de la
poudre aux yeux vous parlais tout à
l'heure de démocratie participative
finalement on a le sentiment qu'on en
est loin en fait la méthode était très
intéressante c'était une première ça
portait exane énormément d'espoir parce
que pour une fois les yeux de citoyens
étaient vraiment en responsabilité
c'était à eux de s'exprimer de choisir
les mesures qui faisait du sens autant
en matière de protection du climat que
de justice sociale et c'était vraiment
tout l'enjeu de cette convention
je pense qu'elle sera répliquée caraes
elle a instauré en fait un climat
extrêmement positif au sein de ses
citoyens leurs retours d'expérience sont
d'ailleurs extrêmement positif
beaucoup d'entre eux ont du mal même à
se quitter après cette convention
citoyenne et à se dire que c'est fini
donc je pense que le concept même de
convention citoyenne va faire des émules
on va la retrouver ailleurs sur les
territoires par contre ça a renforcé le
sentiment que de nouveaux mécanismes
sont absolument nécessaires pour
justement impliqué mieux nos citoyens et
ça le gouvernement n'a pas réussi
finalement à apprendre le coche à aller
jusqu'au bout
on voit qu'il ya encore trop de
réticences à inclure les citoyens dans
la gouvernance et c'est extrêmement
dommage mais il faut bien voir que le
mandat d' emmanuel macron pas toucher à
sa fin un jour nous aurons d'autres
dirigeants et peut-être que justement
des réformes de fond vont s'amorcer pour
une meilleure démocratie participative à
l'avenir merci beaucoup à vous marrez
m'a calmé je rappelle que vous êtes un
président de l'association wild légal